last time I saw you guys I was pregnant
very kind words for me as I entered in
some mother but do you guys bring the
kids when you come to these kind of
things no I think we do but like this
it's just hard because it's hit or miss
I'm what we can do with them and it's
limited on what they can do it though
tells they're four and two it's like
having two pet piranhas are you kidding
me
they're cute cuddly piranhas we can't
take them everywhere it's nice to have
some time for just seeing how to get out
- I was gonna say it's like a weakness
weekend of date nights for you guys what
have you been able to do have you been
able to spend some alone time together
we have lots of room service and then
when daddy goes to do the interviews mom
goes to the spa
last time I saw you - you had not
announced the Warner Brothers deal yet
since then you're with Warner Brothers
Records number-one album congratulations
I now hear you on the radio all the time
in Los Angeles
what's that adventure been like for you
well it's been kind of a waiting game to
be honest with you I feel like you feel
the ripples and you see the effects once
you get out of the road y'all know that
my road life and my schedule my band is
kind of the wheelhouse of our
organization and you know I think when
we sign the deal I had no I didn't know
what a major release was gonna feel like
obviously when the record went number
one I thought well that's that's enough
right there now that we're getting
placement on radio stations we're
getting some airplay on radio stations
that we haven't had the opportunity to
play on in the last ten years we're
starting to really see the effects of
radio play and our stuff so for
everybody in radio thank you for playing
the first one we put out how proud are
you so proud it's awesome and actually
the interview is the first hint that we
were gonna sign and people kind of
caught that yeah it was great that was
like the first little step to the fans
realizing that we were talking about
signing and everything but it's been
great just been a lot of hard work and
making sure that we're doing the right
thing for everybody that depends on us
in our organization all the families and
I'm so excited I love hearing that now
what's the next big dream for you
you know I think that once we accomplish
what we want to hope to accomplish with
radio and single placement and you know
I would I would like to think that this
time next year maybe we could be
eligible for something here or or have a
part in the show we can become more of
the family I think that I've held back a
lot of ideas and creativity over the
years because I haven't had the means we
haven't at the time and I think I'm
anxious to see what I come up with with
my producer Trent Willman and everybody
over at Warner in the next couple years
as far as projects and fun stuff show
ideas and well in the meantime don't you
have a big gig with mr. George Strait
coming up yes we do we've sold out the
ramen this year and I thought that was
cool and then we had to move a sold-out
show in Texas around so we could go play
and open up for Blake Shelton and George
Strait pretty pretty cool I got a treat
like every other day um you know I treat
this like an athlete would I like to be
on top of my game and I don't really
think about it too much I go in there do
my job music hopefully I've got a couple
ideas for the new single I would like
for on my way to you get to number one
first before we start picking the new
ones plant that little seed